hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes art and
tosses it into an arena where it will
fight for our amusement i'm your host
mark ellis and today on the show it is i
who will be thrust into a kick-ass keanu
conundrum because battling it out will
be two of his finest franchises waging
war for all-time action supremacy by now
you might have pieced together that the
keanu in question is not the adorable
kitty from that key and peel movie
although it was really cute hey this is
keanu reeves and he's decidedly more of
a dog person of course there's no bill
and ted or point break on this episode
instead it'll be a bullet bending bad
guy bashing bloodbath between the john
wick trilogy and the three matrices see
i did pay attention to trigonometry yeah
sure
in one corner you have the matrix and
its two sequels reloaded and revolutions
the sci-fi action masterpiece that
allowed us to see the world for what it
really is not the facade that it appears
all i'm offering is the truth you know
what in case any of you all opted to
take the blue pill i don't want to ruin
your fun
just in the other corner it's john wick
and his two sequels the assassin lead
fight fest that taught us all the most
important lesson in life do not mess
with another person's dog on that
we agree
even if it's one of those tiny ones that
barks like every eight seconds and lives
in the apartment right above me
serenity now here's how we'll determine
a winner round one box office round two
tomato meter slash audience score round
three iconic moments round four legacy
and then we'll do a wild card round that
could involve what's cooler to wear
while beating the crap out of someone
futuristic leather or a finely tailored
suit personally i'm gonna go with a suit
because if the fight doesn't end in my
favor and look at me it probably won't
i'll save my beautiful widow some
pennies at the funeral by already
dressing myself for the occasion but neo
and john wick they've been described as
everything from mid-level programmers to
the boogeyman incarnate we call him
and the one thing that they do have in
common well they don't die they just
might have to find a different chain
hotel to crash at from time to time
gentlemen this institution is now
deconsecrated these are two keanu
characters who don't care about
redeeming their pro football career
don't have time to wish eddie van halen
into their band
and we'll never yell the phrase i am an
fbi agent the matrix is going sunglasses
to tie against john wick let's get it on
and away we go
round one box office if your name is
keanu reeves and you were in 1989's
parenthood then you've had many a good
day at the box office but few years can
top what you did in 1999 and 2014. those
marked two pivotal points in your career
because each one saw a new flick with
your name on it rise out of obscurity
and surprise us by becoming a box office
behemoth and if your name is keanu
reeves and you aren't a famous actor i
bet you love the conversation that
ensues every time you make a reservation
at the outback steakhouse how do you
know all this try the cheese fries no i
don't think i will the matrix entered
the summer of 1999 as an interesting
also ram to more anticipated movie going
fare like star wars return to the big
screen with the phantom menace and a
tiny little camcorder flick called the
blair witch project was it real
[Applause]
but the matrix would emerge as nothing
short of a cultural revolution in terms
of cinema action special effects and
fight choreography directed by the
wachowskis and featuring a number of
future john wick enthusiast in front of
and behind the lens the first film of
that trilogy would go on to gross 465
million dollars worldwide
that's interesting that's good enough to
get two sequels greenlit that would be
shot back to back and released within
months of each other in 2003 reloaded
soared even higher hauling in doctor
evil numbers like 739 million bucks
internationally right
with 281 mil of that ringing up cash
registers here in the united states that
was the comet then revolutions was the
afterglow earning a still stratospheric
427 million dollars around the globe i
am a trafficker of information i know
everything i can as we look back with
rose tinted glasses and slick leather
trench coats how impressive is it that
in the span of a few years a property
helmed by newer directors and one
semi-bankable star would completely
shift the filmmaking landscape while
earning well over 1.5 billion dollars on
the way
okey-dokey
would we ever see a phenomenon like that
again
well we might or maybe we already have
and it started the same leading actor
john wick arrived in 2014 and snuck up
on moviegoers even more so than the
matrix it was just some stylized counter
reeves little action film right well
maybe but it hit the multiplex sweet
spot and was a sleeper hit hauling in 86
million dollars worldwide on a minuscule
budget under the table is where she gets
done word of mouth continued to spread
and in the process sequels were greenlit
and surpassed the dollar power of the
original chapter 2 did 171 million
across the globe then para bellum almost
doubled that raking in 326 million
dollars in those gold coins that can be
used for weird clandestine services you
want to pay your bar tab use a gold coin
want to get a bigger bazooka use the
same gold coin you keen on earning a
coin the matrix is at a clear earnings
advantage in this round but i will point
out that while that franchise peaked
dollars and cents wise at part two john
wick just kept gaining more and more
traction with each new flick in fact
para bellum actually outgrossed
revolutions here in the states by a
score of 171 million dollars to 139
million bucks take that agent smith why
do you persist but the matrix can
quickly counter just by its insane dvd
sales augmented by perfect technological
transition timing see kids back in the
late 90s early 2000s when your host was
just a dummy in school dreaming of one
day being a dummy on something called an
internet or a peacock vhs was all the
rage for home movie consumption but a
funny thing happened on the way to
circuit city
dvds came on the scene and after a brief
skirmish with something called divx look
it up i swear it was a close ball game
for a while you get caught using that
yeah i know this never happened those cd
looking things planted their flag in all
of our houses and video game consoles
released right in the thick of this
metamorphosis the matrix became the
first film to cross 1 million dvd sales
and by the time the sequels arrived that
first flick had sold 30 million copies
and it was the second dvd purchased by
both myself and our expert researcher
mark hoffmeyer his first disc was of
course deep blue sea mine
days of thunder i'm dropping the hammer
what i'm from the south and i wanted to
hear the start your engines were on my
family's new speakers robin's racing
just slammed into me no he didn't slam
you he didn't bump you he didn't nudge
you he rubbed you and robin's son is
racing speaking of racing this first
round sees the matrix off to a hot start
team neo gets a convincing win and goes
up on johnny dubs one to nothing take it
back round two tomato meter slash
audience score sure stylized action and
cool looking clothing help a starly
kiana reeves pack movie theaters but how
did these films do once we were walking
out of the theater probably on our way
to banana republic to get a slim fit
suit or hot topic to see if they carry
those shiny trench coats well before we
break down how these two seminal action
franchises did on the tomato meter and
audience score scales i feel compelled
to remind me that the bill and ted
trilogy has a fresh average of 73
percent no way
and point break is also shooting a fresh
curl at 69 percent the point break
remake 11
cause you deserve
now to the task at hand the term
parabellum is found in latin as part of
a phrase meaning if you want peace you
must prepare for war
so it will be a tug of war between
critics and fans or will it be all peace
and love for the badass killer whose
dating profile definitely says must love
dogs is that the dog
he likes you by the way that movie must
love dogs 36 of the tomato meter come on
where's your heart critics i'm shocked
and sad luckily john wick is as fresh as
his suit at least as it was at the start
of the film john wick is 86 on the
tomato meter and his two sequels both
check in at 89 each damn
it's christmas
we're going to applebee's after this
wow action films don't usually get
better with each subsequent entry even
terminator 2 isn't as fresh as the first
one although it's much better hasta la
vista baby the audience score pulls off
the same trick part 1 is 81 chapter 2
climbed to 85 percent and parabellum
brings nothing but peace with a 96
yeah i think he's back
i'm thinking so
the matrix clearly woke up mr wick and
might have upset his dog because dude
came into this round with a vengeance
can neo morpheus and trinity match him
and go up two to nothing this is a war
well they're off to a hot start the
matrix og is super fresh on both
accounts as its 85 audience score is
further buoyed by its 88 tomato meter
rating the entire franchise remains
fresh on the audience side of the aisle
with reloaded gathering a 72 percent and
revolutions squeaking into freshville
with an even 60
reloaded helps keep the matrices in the
ball game here by sporting a 73 tomato
meter score all right revolutions it's
all on you i'm ready two outs bottom of
the ninth can you deliver like return of
the jedi slash king did and two other
prominent film trilogy you know what no
i can't even hype this up the answer is
a solid no well that didn't go so well
revolutions landed with a thud on the
tomato meter with a rotten 35
i'm sure it has its defenders one of
whom i'll probably run into on the hit
podcast rotten tomatoes is wrong
available on apple podcasts or wherever
you enjoy your content but that basement
dweller really makes it tough to get a w
here so we go to the law of averages
john wick features a bulletproof 87.3
percent audience score average to the
matrix is cc's 72.3 percent which my
expert trigonometry training tells me is
15
less it's an even bigger disparity on
the tomato meter john wick actually
improves on its audience score promise
climbing to an 88 average with the
critics the matrix well the good news is
it's still fresh but it's a far cry from
its competitor with just 65.3 percent as
its average but those dvd sales
oh right we already mentioned that in
the last round sorry i get excited i
miss collecting physical media now all
my content is in some cyber cloud which
sounds
kind of like a movie franchise i enjoy
called
the matrix look it all came full circle
look you played tough here but this john
wick guy is zestfully fresh team dog
lover gets the win in round two and
we're tied one to one grazie round three
iconic moments
fair warning this round will be
jam-packed and stuffed to the brim with
killer action memorable scenes and maybe
even some musical accompaniment
but really seeing the awesome display of
choreography stunt work and imagination
in all six of these movies can really be
summed up by a single word
couldn't have said it better myself so
let's start with that revolutionary film
that was such a revolution it came out
four years before its sequel that was
called revolutions
sure we all love the red pill blue pill
conundrum that sets our hero down his
path of living up to all that the one
hype but can you dear viewer remember
which pill it was it offered the truth
about reality that yep it was the red
one which one would you take i would
have gone red pill but then i'd quickly
have asked for all the blue pills once i
had the full understanding that the
matrix isn't just about a pill it also
involves a stunning sequence where we
wake up in a weird gooey cocoon thing
that reminds one of fire in the sky it's
a pretty sweet setup for the challenges
that await but i want no part of it
one of those challenges would be
mastering bullet time this is what
initially helped the matrix stand out
amongst the other action sci-fi
favorites day and these inventive
efforts still hold up over two decades
later neo is still learning his craft
when he gets agent smith for the first
and second and third time and the
fashion department gets high praise for
figuring out the perfect clothes to
accentuate the new era of slo-mo stunt
and wire work but just as fun to watch
in retrospect is the master student
battle between lawrence fishburne's
morpheus and neo and if it's fight
scenes you like the matrix trilogy
didn't just leave that dirty work up to
the boys the inaugural film gives us
legendary moments like the subway fight
and the lobby shootout but we would be
struggling if we didn't have carrie anne
moss's trinity running literally all
over the city kicking ass and burning
tons of calories disarming a gaggle of
cops in the opening sequence at
eventually rescuing morpheus later in
the film dodge this the matrix and john
wick both do a fantastic job of
ingratiating us quickly into the vibe
that will remain relatively consistent
throughout their respective franchises
but no i refuse to list johnny's poor
doggy's fate as an iconic moment i know
it sets off the chain of events that
last all the way past john wick chapter
three parabellum but i'm not harping on
that nasty game of thrones fella and
what he did to that poor doggy i love
dogs however i will say that when dude's
daddy vigo gets wind about what his son
did to john wick's puppy his expression
says it all that
nobody
is john blake you have awoken a sleeping
giant ass hickory and susan doesn't let
up for the next 90 minutes and we get
the line that sells the film when john
wick utters i'm thinking i'm back the
fun of john wick is that he can end you
in a variety of visually splendid ways i
once saw him kill three men in a bar
with a pencil we could go with a fun
location like the bathhouse brawl or the
club fight from the og or he can simply
kill you with a pencil i know i've heard
the story sir [ __ ] pencil as we see
in john wick too but my creme de la
creme is from parabellum looking a
little run down there john when early on
he sends nba star bobon marjanovic to
his maker with a book yeah a book when
we said hitting the books would be the
death of us that was a college metaphor
but this seven foot hulk actually got
killed with a novel john wick would
really be good at cutthroat improv give
him an object he'll find a way to murder
you
back in the matrixville the sequels were
as thrilling as they were confusing but
for every head-scratching expository
sequence we were also treated to
splendid visuals that led us into
important battles check out how cocky
our little neos become with his
abilities when he takes on maravingian
and a whole crap ton of bullets let us
find out where this goes saviors they
grow up so fast the film also features a
breathtaking feast for all six of hayley
joel osmet's senses with the zion rave
party and once again trinity shows us
all how it's done when she escapes a
host of nefarious agents all roads or
rather electrical wiring led to the
moments we witness in the matrix
revolutions when the epic climactic
battle between neo and agent smith does
not disappoint mr anderson welcome back
we missed you
some five years of mastering a new
generation of effects martial arts and
complicated wire work paid off in this
battle but the build-up throughout the
third chapter is not to be forgotten
there's a heart-wrenching attack on zion
and the end seen as we make our way to
machine city the townships in the matrix
really spell it out for you don't they
what do you want
peace
as for brave sir wick he just keeps
getting better at murdering his fellow
assassins
throughout the trilogy as more and more
independent contractors take an interest
in being the one that brings down john
wick the dude keeps inventing new ways
to get at them first i love the weapons
museum fight and parabellum simply
because of its resourcefulness and the
humor wedged in works too just check out
that knife fight when both parties
realize simultaneously hey what's right
behind us a bunch of antique sharp
objects waiting to check in
animals exact some long-awaited revenge
in that closing film of the trilogy as
well we get horse kicks and german
shepherd bites and it's a real win for
all of us animal lovers out there
you a dog person john if i had to tee up
one more iconic moment from each
franchise it'd still be two glorious
fight scenes first up matrix reloaded
when neo shows off his upgraded fighting
skills against a few game agents that
went as expected it's always enjoyable
when the boy from the first film becomes
a badass man right before our eyes as
for boogeyman john wick it's got to be
that chapter 2 mirror room escapade you
wanted me back
i'm back it gives me a headache thinking
about how director chad stachelski shot
that with minimal use of cgi we don't
see any cameras in these reflective
surfaces at all just a ton of kick-ass
martial arts action both film trilogies
reward audiences for their loyalty by
upping the antsy with every new battle
and each subsequent villainous attack
that's a nice trick but whereas the
matrix never strayed too far from the
original's battle plans john wick kept
inventing visually electrifying methods
to dispose of antagonists sure the
matrix had a much more involved story it
was hugo weaving and that may serve it
well as we progress in this episode but
if you're talking iconic moments i gotta
go with the movie set that delivers the
most pound for pound thrills and that is
john wick team continental wins the
round and goes up 2-1 this isn't over
round four legacy
well this has been a fun walk down a
decidedly bullet-riddled memory lane but
when we look back on these two dynamic
trilogies that will both have new canon
added soon it's not worthy to take a few
steps back and look at the cultural
footprint they've each left in our pop
culture consciousness
life is suffering the matrix and john
wick have both left sizeable marks on
hollywood and beyond but whose legacy is
richer i'm a huge fan
john
wick
the matrix has an advantage right out of
the gate because the old adage of age
before beauty doesn't really work here
it's still gorgeous and is the elder
statesman of our competitors today and
it may be the most referenced film from
all of 1999 which is no small feat
because again it came out the same years
that star wars awoke from a 16-year
theatrical nap what does that got to do
with anything and no i'm not counting
the re-releases because han shot first
i bet you have
the galaxy far far away casts a large
shadow over all other film franchises
but when paired up the matrix showed
even die hard phantom menace honks that
there were new creative geniuses in town
and they are the wachowskis lana and
lily have become relevant for so many
reasons outside of their filmmaking
prows but it was the technological
advances from that first film that made
us take notice how many times in one's
movie-going career can you honestly say
you were blown away in the theater maybe
that first star wars in 1977 if you
experienced it now i am the master
1993's jurassic park but anyone who went
to see the matrix on the big screen that
year left a changed cinephile and the
world would never be the same
welcome
to the real world that can certainly be
said for anyone who is taking muay thai
kung fu or any other martial arts
lessons after seeing the john wick
movies whereas most of the matrix stunts
can be reenacted by us underwater wick
battles don't spare the courtesy of
slo-mo they're fast furious and
endlessly creative
yeah
i kind of enjoyed that the gunfu style
fighting scene throughout the trilogy is
a melding of multiple martial arts forms
and the weapons training was just as
intense for the performers as it was
entertaining for us in the crowd
somebody please
get this man
a gun
stunt work and big screen brawls were
permanently altered after the first john
wick film and with every new picture the
gold standard for a battle scene has
been reset to a higher plateau
as unattainable as his killing a guy
with office supplies ability might be
john wick also gets points for
relatability we all love dogs even cat
people
me
i'm more of a
cat person myself look i had cats and
dogs growing up so i'm happy to be the
switzerland for this pet debate but it's
the cardinal scent of any movie since
turner and hooch to not let the dog make
it
this
this dog's nuts my theory is that if the
dog in independence day could avoid
obliteration by aliens they all should
be able to survive a two-hour run time
the first john wick took a risk in
bucking that trend but in doing so made
us root even harder for john himself who
amongst us wouldn't really want revenge
on literally anyone associated with
anyone who even looked at our puppy with
an evil eye obviously i wouldn't know
since no one has ever said anything but
glowing compliments about my dog molly
the wonder pup but i can imagine it and
i do not like it he was a good dog i
have enjoyed his company whereas john
wick's legacy will be remembered
primarily as one of close quarters
combat with a dash of humor and a pinch
of unique hotel amenities how good is
your laundry
i'm sorry to say that no one's that good
the matrix will be hailed as the next
step in cinema not just in terms of
battlefield artistry but also in
storytelling that doesn't hold our hand
the trilogy does confound me quite often
but that's only because its ambition far
outweighs that of its opponent john wick
if jon eats it we'll all be okay but if
neo can't live up to his promise then a
whole bunch of folks could feel the
ripple effect the mythology might move
at a breakneck pace but that's necessary
for the scope of tail it's weaving i
love saying hugo's last name in this
episode but the wachowskis aren't
without compassion for their viewers
they know we need a breath every now and
again so they slow-mo
seriously how cool is stuff like that
[Music]
ever since the matrices so many flicks
have copied the feel of those high-wire
combat sequences the eastern influence
that molded the matrix is now prevalent
in everything from the underworld movies
to the resident evil films to crouching
tiger hidden dragon and even the biggest
comic book blockbusters of today john
wick made up the fight game ante and we
see evidence of that in actioner's
census debut in 2014 but while raising
the bar is nice completely changing the
game is better and that's exactly what
the matrix did more inventive than i
hate to say it star wars the phantom
menace and more ambitious than even the
blair witch project in the summer of 99
neo and company have continued to
influence the way movies are made
decades after the fact and that feels
like it's good enough to get a win in
the legacy round so we're tied at two to
two heading into the final fight and now
it's time for the wild card round the
keanu of it all
ah keanu reeves we love him we revere
him and he's been a fan favorite ever
since he stumbled into a phone booth and
traveled back in time thanks to george
carlin
strange things are afoot at the circle k
and when it comes down to his
performances in the matrix and john wick
films us as the people of earth are once
again forced to answer that eternal
question
is keanu a great actor what are you
trying to tell me
that i can dodge bullets
is he even a good actor do we just like
him and give the rest the pass or is he
one of the best performers of our time
you want a war
or do you want to just give me a gun if
it's in rolls within his wheelhouse
guns
lots of guns if you look down the line
at reeves filmography any one movie you
point to could provide a dramatically
different answer to those questions bill
and ted he's great excellent
point break he's pretty good you mad
bram stoker's dracula
oh boy i've seen many strange things
already but of particular interest in
this round day keanu isn't just what
film franchise he's better in there's
also unique connective tissue between
these two cinematic achievements that go
way beyond just keanu reeves john wick
was directed by david leach and his
longtime collaborator chad stahelski
chad began his career in la wild land
working with martial arts training and
was the body double for his buddy
brandon lee on the crow after lee's
tragic death during production chad
stood in for his fallen comrade and
helped complete the film he would go on
to be one of the stunt folk on the
matrix and he was promoted to stunt
coordinator on the two sequels since
he's helmed the two john wick sequels by
himself but that's not the end of the
matrix pipeline several stunt and fight
coordinators also returned to work once
again with reeves after initially
meeting him on the matrix films as for
keanu reeves himself he's pretty good at
both roles although neo asks a lot of
him from a character growth perspective
no
i can't do that he has to capably pull
off a dead end-ish computer programmer
then a few scenes later he's got to
fight morpheus with newly acquired
intellect and skills then he has to
battle a host of agents all while having
the label of the one on his shoulders
but you know no pressure kid john wick
goes through some changes for sure but
he's pretty much the same dude from the
beginning of the first film through the
end of chapter three albeit with a ton
more bumps bruises and achy bones
you look as bad as i feel
and a suit that desperately needs to
visit milton eddy's 24 7 dry cleaners in
the valley get their free popcorn i love
candy what stands out to me about john
wick is that this is a character
designed to fit inside of what counter
reeves can do and he absolutely crushes
it tell them
tell them all
his narrow focus on the mission at hand
his confidence and his abilities even as
he's inwardly acknowledging how
exhausted he is and those martial arts
skills that's vintage keanu reeves
he came into the role of neo very well
too at the first film's outset he's
right on par with the movie star we've
come to enjoy in the decade that we had
known up to that time but while both his
character and the audience are having a
ton of new mind-blowing information
thrown at them neo's understanding and
acceptance of his recently gained powers
and knowledge move at a more gradual
pace it's a more nuanced performance
than he got credit for at the time
but the matrix films weren't just about
keanu reeves legend has it that at one
point will smith was offered the role of
neo and turned it down
and while the sequels made the matrix
mythology even more dense neo himself
seems to have plateaued to a degree
it was a ton of learning on a very steep
curve early on but by the time we hit
the revolutions movie the storytelling
and visuals became so convoluted and
overwhelming that any actor's
performance got somewhat lost in the
watch what's the problem with you people
you can't think but five minutes in
front of your face john wick may not
sport the most character growth i've
ever seen but unlike the matrix maybe
that was the point it's not just about
how ambitious a film is it's whether you
can pull it off the matrix gets too far
out and dense at times for my simpleton
brain but john wick keeps its formula
simple the plot is usually just
assassins battling each other but the
war continues to evolve in fantastical
ways there's always new wrinkles like
the gold coins or the parabellum russian
crime outfit that wick does have ties to
even as keanu's john is plodding along
defeating anybody who would look the
wrong way at his dog we see the wheels
turning as he's figuring out his next
move
what must be done the matrix is by far
the most important singular film on
counter reeves resume it broke new
ground and as we saw at the top of this
round it helped form the crew of john
wick rather nicely but if we're
comparing the trilogies as a whole my
take is that the matrix got a bit too
bloated and dry with the sequels and
some of the moments feel a little stale
ironically even as the john wick films
all have that simple premise they always
feel fresh and new life lesson kids
simplicity isn't always what you do if
you can't achieve something more
complicated sometimes keeping it simple
is the goal
[Music]
yeah
i admire the ambition of the wachowskis
and their baby trilogy of the matrix and
i'm genuinely excited to go back and
take the right pill again with the
upcoming flick but in terms of both
keanu reeves as an actor and the trilogy
as a whole the john wick movies knew
exactly what they wanted and they got
the most out of it i have served
i will be of service john wick gets the
win in the wild card round and pulls off
with many in las vegas and the internet
would consider an upset by winning the
match that was a pretty good fight huh
yeah
i know i know if you're upset that i
ruled against such an influential
mind-bending property like the matrix i
get it but just think about how hard it
was for me to make that call i'm the
same guy that briefly thought the movie
hackers was the best film ever simply
because it was so much fun to watch fast
typing back in the 1990s oh man
it's universally stupid man aol was
given 10 free hours of internet like it
was candy and it was all about how many
words could you belt onto a computer
screen in under a minute as opposed to
now when it took me like 450 spelling
errors until i was finally ready to turn
this script in i'm going to be honest
look my chubby fingers were meant for
getting stuck in bowling balls not
writing
a true tragedy and of course all of this
is just my opinion
except the whole all dogs should survive
movies thing that is a fact and it is
undisputed as for john wick versus the
matrix the battle now rages on to you my
friend yes you hit me up on social media
at mark ellis live with your take and
let's have a fun congenial spirited
debate about who's right thank you to
everyone behind the scenes here that
makes the matrix that is rotten tomatoes
come smoothly you've been watching
versus i'm mark ellis and i'll take the
blue pill
not that blue pill get your mind out of
the gutter
you